[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the
virtual edition of our year-round member
screening series
film independent presents my name is
alexander greer
and i am a documentary alumni of film
independence los angeles film festival
um and before we get started i want to
give a special mention to some of film
independence loyal supporters
thank you to our incredible lead sponsor
the hollywood foreign press association
our virtual screening partner vision
media
and our official media partner the los
angeles times
and promotional partner kcrw
for anybody that hasn't seen it yet uh
well first let's stop and go watch it
immediately because this is an
excellent film and i'm really excited to
talk with these two directors um
class action park is what we're here to
talk about today which
tells the story of one of the most
notorious
and infamous theme parks to ever exist
whose
danger excess and reckless abandon for
the public good
was matched only by the era in which it
was manifested which was
1980s united states of america
it's available to stream right now on
hbo max
and i'm here today with the film's
co-directors seth porgis
and chris charles scott iii
i'm always interested to to know what's
going on in people's backgrounds where
are you guys
zooming from this day chris where are
you
i am in bisbee arizona
yeah beautiful bisbee arizona
beautiful bisbee arizona very beautiful
artist
community here uh former miner mining
town
down here doing some filming and hanging
out with friends who actually own a
hotel here
so i'm in business by coincidence
friends of mine as well but we didn't
realize this until like four days ago
so oh wow yeah um and i'm up in uh
beacon new york
well fun yeah you've got a much more
minimalist atmosphere going on than
chris does in the background there chris
you got a lot of good shots keys it
looks like
i'm in my friend's key store object
limited
29 main street bisbee arizona it is
literally a chachi store so
yeah good good yeah i'm good with the
verbiage
apparently um so with
any documentary uh it's it's it's always
a
long and storied road from finding
something that you want to tell
a story about to actually having it uh
you know
be available to watch and uh i mean wow
is it available to watch it's on hbo max
excellent platform and i was looking you
guys got a hundred percent
sitting on rotten tomatoes right now
which must feel
really excellent and quite the
accomplishment uh so at this point in
the road i wanted to invite you guys to
look back and tell me
how how you came across this story or
how you decided that you wanted to tell
this story
and how you got it to this place that
we're at today yeah i'll i'll jump in
here so i've been
immersed in the world of ash park
absolutely obsessed with the story
uh for pretty much my whole life you
know i went to action park as a kid
and anybody who goes to action park sort
of comes away with
very strange experiences very strange
memories
and you know i grew up going to all
sorts of amusement parks and theme parks
universal studios
disney six flags whatever and it's very
clear from the moment you walk up to
action park the action park is
very different from all those what i
like to say is when you walk up to
disneyland the first thing you see is
like a big castle
when you walk up the action park first
thing you see is a giant loop-de-loop
water slide it's at the gate
it's like taunting you it's a symbol
telling you everything here
is weird the rules of god and man don't
apply here
this is a very different and strange
place but i went there
as a very young kid and only a couple of
times so i had these memories
of crazy looping water slides and just
like bodies flopping around and fights
breaking out
and violence and blood and all these
things that as i got older
didn't square with my idea of how
society works how how the world
functions
there's no way that was real and so i
began to sort of
doubt my own memories maybe that was
something i saw on tv maybe that was
like a looney tunes cartoon that sort of
seeped in right
and as i got older i started looking
into the topic of action park and
finding most of what was out there
on the internet was you know a couple
weird new jersey articles the thinly
thinly sourced wikipedia page a lot of
myth a lot of legend
very little in terms of of journalism a
fact of interview of the things that i
as a journalist kind of
looked to and i started becoming very
interested in sort of digging into this
topic to effectively fact check
my own memories but also to see what of
the greater legend that the greater myth
of action park was actually true
um and so i started writing articles
about it and giving lectures on in like
2008 or 2009
uh in 2013 i worked on a documentary
short
on the topic with my friends uh matt and
anthony
that ended up going quite viral and that
was really amazing because i think that
was the first time
that it went viral i think for a very
specific reason and that's that a lot of
people from new jersey
had a similar experience as i did which
was they would tell people
these stories these memories these these
things they've encountered at action
park and people wouldn't believe them
because it sounds like a bunch of dudes
from new jersey just making stuff up you
know
it's like oh yeah i went down this water
slide and like who believes that guy you
know
and so we did this and we actually
interviewed people who were close to
sort of upper levels of management at
the park and they effectively confirmed
a lot of these rumors and so people from
new jersey started passing this video
around
as basically validation as proof like to
their spouses saying see i wasn't lying
you know so it became like this they
went very
viral in that sense and something
amazing happened after we released that
and that's my inbox just started
getting messages from people who worked
at the park or went to the park who
basically said
something along the lines of you're just
scratching the surface i
solve things there's so much more so
much more i started getting these
stories and collecting stories not
really
sure what i would end up doing with them
talking to people and really kind of
piecing together what the larger story
was here
and then uh early last year i was
visiting my good friend chris charles
scott in las vegas
uh my wonderful friend wonderful
filmmaker and we were just getting a
drink
we were talking and chris basically is
like why haven't you
done anything bigger with all this
action park stuff you've collected
and really it was like right then and
there we said
we're doing it we're doing it uh and
that was april of 2019.
christmas you're muted and by memorial
day uh
2019 we were in new jersey
filming yeah just like two months later
camera's rolling
what a absolutely quick turnaround uh
especially because
i'm gonna jump questions here uh but
like one of the things that really
struck me about this um was the style in
which you told it which obviously when
you're doing a story on anything that
happened in the past you have to rely on
archival footage
um and you guys just had like a
treasure trove of what seemed to be home
movies
yeah like i'm assuming those were those
just home movies
sourced from people absolutely signal up
and people send them to you you know it
was it was really as simple as us
finding people you know so you'd find
somebody on youtube and put up like a
snippet of their home movie
footage you try to reverse engineer
their contact information from their
username
you'd reach out to them and then they'd
say oh i've actually got two hours of
this stuff
you know it would be something like that
and so it's a lot of detective work a
lot of investigative work a lot of just
throwing it out there to the world like
i kind of became sort of known in the
action park world because of my earlier
shorts some of the articles i've done
so i had people reaching out to me who
were just kind of here's our home movies
so yeah a ton of home movies a ton of
home movies some old action park ads
there's that great episode of
headbangers ball that we
feature um but yeah mostly just people's
movies
i was like go ahead dolphin with a guy
in
uh prim nevada and he had just a random
dude he goes
what do you do i said i make
documentaries cause what are you working
on so working on this documentary about
a water park in new jersey action park
he goes
oh my god i grew up going to action park
and my mother
has vhs's in her garage
um so we could not get away from from
action park in the influence
and these people would reach out to us
one guy who reached out over facebook
goes
i have footage and by that evening he
had it digitized and sent to us and
so the action part continues i mean the
the constituency with the action part
they're ready for this movie
yeah that's that's one of the coolest
elements of making a documentary is that
when you decide to tell a story about
something that affected so many
people you end up getting connected with
all of those affected people and you
kind of share in this moment
absolutely but also like getting all
these people's home movies put you guys
in a uniquely privileged position
i'm just imagining i'm imagining you
guys making this movie i'm imagining you
in the edit bay
like logging footage and going through
people's i'm going through people's
personal home movies
and i can only imagine some of the stuff
that ended up on the cutting room floor
because it was totally
irrelevant to the story but do you guys
remember any like
particularly weird stuff that you took
out from these whole movies
i think by time it ended up in our inbox
they had kind of done
they had removed the their birthday
parties and their varmints
and their weddings from it but maybe
maybe i'm missing some anecdotes
well i mean that's awesome um
let's see so
in grouping together like
this entire shared nostalgia
like i mean like you said seth like you
were you were trying to
factualize something that you had maybe
forgotten or you maybe had misremembered
or you thought that might not have been
real
um in doing that you guys make some
pretty
big and interesting cultural insights
um i mean you you you expand the scope
from
from being just a story about a crazy
water park to being a story about
uh an era and a culture and
an ethos that has uh largely as you say
faded and i couldn't tell by the end of
the movie if you guys were
nostalgic and in want of that or if you
were happy that we've moved on
from from that sort of uh existence i
was wondering if you could talk more on
that
i think that confusion is exactly the
point you know i think
this this movie is somewhat i don't
wanna you know it's been
challenging for some people i think
because they want to be told what to
think
uh they want to say like was this guy
goodbye guy or bad guy was this park a
good thing or a bad thing where the 80s
a good thing
or a bad thing and this isn't the movie
kind of movie where we come out and we
you know have a political point of view
or strong anything you
want to tell you think we want to tell
you how it was and i think different
people walk away from it
with different interpretations honestly
but i think if you're going to say what
is this movie really about in that sense
it's about the duality of how both those
things can exist
i mean our interview subject uh chris
gather put it so brilliantly at the end
of the movie
when he kind of talks about how people
from this generation
can simultaneously look back at these
things they experience as children and
be
so grateful that they had the
opportunity to grow up that way with
that freedom and those experiences
and simultaneously be absolutely furious
that that's how they had to grow up
and how nostalgia can both be something
where you look back at it fondly because
that was your childhood
but the same time you know it was kind
of messed up and i think both those
things can co-exist and that's what
action park was it was this place where
for some people it was the most fun
amazing joyous place in
the world and then for others it was a
place of immense heartache and tragedy
and it could have been that for both
those things for one person with
one minute being one and then the next
minute being the other
and that's really what to me at least
the movie was about and chris what do
you think
when we dug into this movie and i
started figuring out about gene marvel
hill
i wanted gene to be the bad guy so badly
i
needed for him to be my villain but as i
began to get to know gene through the
interviews and through the articles
i
there was this this i don't know this
love affair with gene i liked
gene i understood gene um and so gene to
me was not my villain
i wanted to present the 80s as a
possible villain
uh the type of parenting the latchkey
kids of the 1980s
where you climbed trees and you woke up
in the morning
and you hung out with your friends all
day building tree houses
and having clubs and your parents
weren't even looking for you
and it's so representative of the time
that we live in now where we're having
to isolate
and we're so fearful of the outside of
neighbors and
disease and pandemic
the 80s were like complete opposite of
that like
we took i took myself back to a time i
grew up in a town of 533 people
on the texas louisiana border we didn't
have an action park
but we had cliffs that we jumped off of
in the lake we
had we tried to die for fun
and my cousin after he watched the movie
he goes man this was our childhood
and i was like exactly and so
how you interpret this movie i guess is
about the time
and the place that you grew up my
brother is 32
i'm 39 he watched the documentary and
couldn't understand it
i mean just that few years behind me
because he didn't grow up that way
he grew up with the nintendo's and the
playstations and he didn't have friends
that
he hung out with and went to their
houses and so i guess it's
about the time or place that you grew up
in is how you conclude the movie
did you guys go into it with that
intention because one of the really
things that's interesting about the
structure of the movie is i feel like um
it starts off so whimsical and so fun
and absurd um and then it takes a really
sharp turn into something real and
dangerous
and and difficult and it's it's kind of
like what i'm assuming riding a ride at
action park would would be like
fun at first and then a horrible turn or
visiting the park
uh it's fun in his whimsical uh
it's it's it's a coming of age place for
a lot of young men
in the new jersey era but it did
hurt people it did name people and so
the
the very the very vibe of the movie
reflected the energy that people look
back on the park or
or or the energy of the park while it
existed it's fun
it's whimsical but you can show up
looking to just splash around the wave
pool
and end up dying that was a real
option the the sharp turn in the movie i
think is is
crucial crucial and and i think it's
really interesting
seeing people's responses to it because
like you see words and like reviews
where
people say like it made them feel
uncomfortable or something like that and
i just say
good that is the idea of this movie
this is a movie i i told chris uh i was
like i want to make a movie
where people laugh and then hate
themselves for laughing and
because action park the myth the legend
of action park has become a joke
and it's not a joke because there's like
here's something funny there's a punch
line the joke is so absurd
the mere existence of it is funny the
laughter you get from
looking and reading about political
action is very different from like say
seeing a stand-up comic
or or a comedy show you're just shaking
your head because
laughter is the only emotion that the
only expression
that that can tell tell that story and
because of that action park has
itself become somewhat of a joke this
absurd relic of another time but boy
didn't that sound fun
and i thought it was really important
for us to lean in to that myth and to
show that what that myth was and and to
make people who may not be familiar with
the myth
understand the myth and the legend and
the excitement
and like the giddiness that people have
in the action park and then
totally tear it down as quickly as
possible
i mean and again it's like if you are on
an alpine slide you might be having the
best time of your life and then
five seconds later you're having the
worst time in your life and the distance
between that
is not telegraphed in a traditional
movie structure it's not
you know there's you're not
foreshadowing that's gonna happen it
happens
instantly happens suddenly and we wanted
to turn in the movie to be as close to
reflecting that as possible
even if it maybe even especially if it
made people feel uncomfortable
because if you're going to laugh at
actually we want to give you permission
to laugh like the first
hour the movie is funny it's funny and
we want
and you're allowed to laugh we want
people to laugh we want to make people
laugh
but then we want them to understand what
they were laughing at
and basically say if you want to give
yourself permission to laugh about this
you need to know
what you're laughing at and you guys
executed that masterfully i mean it's
what it's what elevates it from
a short about an oddity to
you know a fighting cultural examination
which is what i'd say the movie is
did you did you know that that was what
you wanted to do with it going into this
story or
was that a conclusion that was only
arrived at after
sitting and reflecting and marinating in
what you were looking at for so long
so i won't hear chris's thoughts on this
but for me
the moment when i think i realized that
was after we had the interview with
esther larson
yes um yeah because up until that point
i think we were both
still drinking the kool-aid a little bit
i think we were both
sort of reveling in the in the getting
nostalgia of action park and laughing
about and viewing it as nothing but a
joke
and not really giving proper examination
to the human toll
the human toll of this place and the
people actually got hurt and people
actually got killed
but once we were in a room with the
larson family it was impossible not to
see that
it was impossible and the juxtaposition
between
the interview with the larsens and some
of the other interviews we had
was so astonishing to us and magnified
both
you know the larson interview was so
tragic and heartfelt
to us because we'd already interviewed
people who had nothing but nice things
to say about the park
and i wanted viewers to go through that
same transformation that we
did where we are laughing and joking
with people about action park
and then it just comes right down the
earth chris what do you think
the larson's interview seth nailed it
that was a turning point for us
we had not interviewed someone who had
had a family member named
seriously or or or killed at the park
and after the larson's interview that
was a turning point for me
you want to talk on how you guys came
across the larsons how that how that
became a part of the story
from a production standpoint yes so seth
and i
we were going over our interview list
and we were like we need a life guard we
need the
security guy we need a patron we need a
and going down the catalog of people
that we needed to
do this we said let's find someone who
was
seriously hurt or had a family member
hurt at the part
we had no idea that the larsons were
still alive if they were in new jersey
and so i said let's look up their family
because any other action park
articles or or news stories about the
park
we did not see the larsons mentioned
or any family of a person killed at the
park
and so we were like maybe these people
don't exist maybe people have tried we
could not believe that no one had
reached out
and so i googled george larson
and an obituary came up and it was
george lawson jr's dad george larson
senior
and he had passed away and
uh it said that he owned a construction
company in the orlando area
we went to that website
wrote i wrote hey i'm chris scott have
done a documentary on actual part in
their
contact us section about 15 minutes
later we get a call
a guy is sobbing on the phone
um i cannot understand a word he's
saying
and he's like give me a minute give me a
minute give me a minute give me a minute
and it was brian larson the brother and
he said we've been waiting on this call
for nearly 40 years nobody had ever
reached out to them
every wow not one in addition it's not
like there's a shortage of people who've
written about
action park myself included um but
nobody ever reached out to him
and what's amazing is that the larsen
death it's mentioned frequently
in articles about action park is one of
the deaths uh in oral histories and
whatnot
it's it's mentioned but the facts that
are out there are
wrong they're just wrong and we've
realized that the the story
of the larsen death was one that had
been somewhat constructed in order to
make it
seem like someone one of the myths of
action park was that this was this
incredible joy land
uh we're going to give you all the tools
of the best time of your life and if you
get hurt it's because you did something
wrong
we're not going to stop you you do
something wrong get hurt that's your
fault
so the story of the larsens was that he
was an employee at the park
operating these rides at night uh racing
friends in the rain in the pitch black
and none of that's true he wasn't an
employee of the park he had previously
operated a ski lift at the sister resort
uh ski resort in a previous season but
they never reported his death to the
state
is what we realized and they never
reports at this stage because basically
they realized they could
claim he was a park employee because he
had worked at the sister ski resort that
was their
dubious explanation the state didn't buy
uh so it was kind of two things one was
they never reported that to the state
the other was they were building up this
myth and the story that it was his fault
and that was that was just astonishing
to me because i see like you know
the media brought into it yeah it seemed
like legitimate like
mainstream news articles very recently
like in past couple months
talking about this and it's always a
part a park employee action park
employee action parking lot wasn't an
action
yeah the the the litigious uh
sidestepping
that mobile hill seemed to do makes him
difficult to feel good for by the time
the movie's over i mean you guys do get
a really good picture of him as this
like uh large life creator and you do
feel sympathy for him but yeah it does
take that turn
lot of um they one of the things i've
seen people like
that frustrates people again this movie
is supposed to be frustrating
is that i think people want us to kind
of have that moralizing like he was a
bad bad man
and if you walk away from this movie
feeling that way that's absolutely fine
but we're
we're journalists we're not gonna it's
not an op-ed
you know like we're telling you things
that happened and you know some of the
people we interviewed about
gene they had very bad things to say
about them and they had some good things
to say about them
and they basically told us like if you
only edit our interview to include the
bad things
you're lying you're just lying and i
think we had a real responsibility
to you know make these humans humans
good people bad people they're humans
they have dimensions to them
and i'm i'm drawn to complex characters
i don't think it's fair
to anybody i think it's overly
simplistic to simply say he's like the
joker you know he's something like
cartoons
um yeah i mean you guys did a great job
of making me not know how to feel at the
end of this but definitely feeling
something
um i'm curious i want to move into
talking about your guys uh working
relationship
uh your co-directors um do you both have
a background in journalism
i've known chris for uh almost a decade
now and
you know it's actually he worked in pr
at the time and i was a journalist
that's what it was
but uh you know but chris moved into
becoming a documentary filmmaker and i
had done some work and like what videos
and whatnot
uh but you know i was the i had the
story and i needed
i needed a partner to execute it and
chris was the this is my man
um and so it really was it was an
awesome working relationship because i
was able to learn so much from chris
about the film making process and i
think at least i hope he learned from me
a little bit about the journalism
process
and we're able to sort of combine forces
and really i think fill in
each other's gaps in a big big way um
you know i i knew the story i knew this
story i had i had the sources i had the
material i had
everything i needed the ability to put
it on celluloid
and chris was my my executor that did it
so so so beautifully
and i mean the the the partnership uh
was unique because
there were things that seth fought for
and i was like you know i just don't get
that
i i don't get that but i'm gonna trust
you
seth on this and there were things that
i fought for
when seth was like i'm going to trust
you on that and it's been reflected in
the reviews that we've been getting
and that have competent on the different
aspects that we both fought for they're
saying that oh i'm glad they
did this i'm glad they did that and so a
lot of
uh looking back on i was like wow seth
okay i apologize you were right
i'm sorry no it really it kind of
reminds me of you know i i really don't
mean to
give us this much credit or or put us on
this pedestal but if you look at like
some of the more interesting creative
partnerships out there like the clash
you got joe strummer and you gotta make
jones or
uh like the beatles mccartney and light
and we're not those guys clearly
but you know they come up with great
music like you can sort of hear the
tension
or you know like see what each person
brought to the table like
uh you know a day in the life the
beatles song oh there's the mccartney
part here's the london part they brought
something together
and i think what made this movie work
like was this really strange
alchemy where these things that i
thought were important about the story
met the things that chris thought were
important about the story and i don't
think it would have been as interesting
we don't think would have been as good a
movie
without that that strange alchemy there
are things i would have completely
missed
and and completely going over my head i
did not think that gene was
a part a huge part of this story
seth educated me
uh uh intently like this he is this has
to go in and yeah
yeah and crazy the whole you know really
making it
about the childhood of so many 1980s
kids
was chris cause chris is a couple years
older than me and i think he understood
that
intuitively in a way that didn't come
quite as immediately to me but once he
once we started talking i understood and
i think that
that and that particularly i think is
why this movie has struck an emotional
chord for so many gen xers in particular
is because they see their own latchkey
childhood reflected in this movie in a
way that i don't think they have in many
places
and that's all chris's brain right there
yeah that's uh a beautiful
partnership um i i could see that with
you being
inside of it and needing the outsider to
be able to draw out a more objective
perspective
yeah literally i've been living i've
been you know forced through the trees
i've been
swimming in this stuff living into so
much that i to some degree i might have
lost
sight of why this is interesting to
people who don't know the story
you know you're not already knee-deep in
the myth of action park
what is it that matters to you and i
think chris who was the outsider
came in with the fresh eyes and was like
this is what it's about
i think that was yeah i'm like seth we
can't interview 40 people
i'm a completist so okay so i know that
uh seth you wanted uh you wanted mobile
hill and
uh chris you you fought you didn't
understand the need for that at first
what was the situation that chris you
saw needing to be in the movie that seth
you might not have seen so much at first
it was the 80s it was really the 80s
stuff it was yeah it was uh
being making about latchkey kit 80's
existence and really making it about
you know an idea like you you may not
have gone to action park because you're
not from the tri-state area
but you had your own action park if you
grew up then you swam in quarries or
jumped off cliffs or broke into
factories or gone to fights or whatever
it is
you know action park is isn't this
unique thing
it's a gated amusement park version of
1980s childhood
i think chris really understood that
yeah that is profound
you guys are kind of uh you guys have
kind of become in my mind at least uh
some very uh astute cultural analysts
um off the cuff question what do you
guys
what do you guys think about the
childhood that's happening
under the cloud of our current events
i mean what what happens to kids who
were you know
10 15 or teenagers the kids who were
growing up formed by
by this world chris you get the tough
ones
yeah so when i hear of my
my friends with kids hold on there's a
truck passing by
but when i hear of my friends with kids
who are raising kids
in this pandemic they're isolated
they're quarantined to their homes they
don't know how the zoom school works
they don't know if they're going to send
their kids back to school and
preceding this this era
parents were were were hovering even
more so
like monitoring whether kids were uh
watching
having play dates uh what what were play
dates
i don't i don't
see and i don't want to sound like an
old fogey but i don't see kids having
that sort of
resilience having that sort of
um scarring that they can
can take care of themselves when things
in the world seems
harmful and and uncertain
um and i don't blame that on the parents
it's just at a time we leave it
living this uncertainty right now and
especially trying to raise kids
through a time like this it's a very
scary place
and not to get very deep here but
i'm black and my brothers have
young children and they're young men
and this the violence that we're seeing
in this the
i i hate that they're having to to to
grow up
in a place that seems so scary that my
brother has to teach his kids
how to talk to cops that not to get
killed
um it's just a weird time
in in everyone's lives right now and
what i like about this film is that
at least for 90 minutes we could take
you back to a time
where things were simple and things did
make sense and
there's an error that we could
romanticize even though there may not
have been a lot of things to romanticize
about
even at the same time you can do that at
the same time say that is
totally messed up how was that ever able
to exist
and that push and pull of nostalgia i
think is really important here this idea
that you can both
look back at something romantically and
also say i'm really glad those days are
behind us
yeah i think what the current time show
or what your guys movie shows us too is
that
you can come out of horrible situations
or you know messed up situations
um stronger at the other end and you can
look back and reflect uh with conflict
but you can still look back
at the various it will also look like
with humor i mean
a lot of people who joke about action
partner people who went there and may
have had
horrific experiences there like there's
a gallows humor to going to and
surviving action park
and i think that we tend to look at
humor
as something that's only appropriate
when things are are light
and not serious but i think the very
existence of humor is like an
evolutionary trait is a coping mechanism
for when things are really harsh
and really hard and i love that kind of
humor
and i think it's really important for us
to acknowledge that kind of humor is
okay and it's okay sometimes
they'll laugh at things that are
terrible
yeah beautifully said beautifully said
um i want to go to audience questions
now because i feel like i'm just
selfishly trying to talk all my ideas
with you guys
and thank you for obliging those um so
just uh to
to remind anybody out there watching
there's a little q a button at the
bottom of the screen that you can type a
question in
uh and i will pair it directly to seth
and chris
uh and we got some good ones on here so
far um this one from
anonymous attendee number seven uh andy
mulvihill's book about his father's park
came out recently did he help or hinder
your project
and how did his book differ from what
you guys found to be the story
i'll handle that uh the mobile family
had nothing to do with the production of
our film
it would have been i think very
difficult for us to make the movie we
made
had day um you know i i wanted
andy to sit for an interview for the
movie because why
wouldn't i uh he declined to i had some
archival footage i've shot of him seven
years ago that we used and is clearly
labeled as archival
uh he neither helped nor hindered our
project he had nothing to do with it to
be honest
um you know he he has his own uh
project kind of in the works around
action park he's trying to you know he
has a tv
uh a scripted project set up um and he
has a book that came out
but he didn't help or heard it um you
know we uh
i i've been in touch with him
sporadically during the production
but in the end he declined to sit for an
interview for the movie and i think
one can understand why it is a very
democratic answer well done um
from matt warren uh he says in talking
about your film
have people come up to you to tell you
about
their own regional version of action
park oh yeah
chris anything what was your regional
action park alex what was your action
park growing up
i grew up in orange county so i was
around uh like the the quote-unquote
like legitimate parks like
uh you know like disneyland and but i
will say uh not
knott's berry farm used to have maybe
they still do they have this thing
called not scary farm that they do
every halloween and um they
they hire a ton of staff like a ton of
people who don't normally work there to
basically run around the park get
dressed up and scare kids
uh and i have a lot of memories of those
scares
being something that like i feel like a
manager at a park wouldn't necessarily
license
i feel like i don't want to say anything
bad about knots i just feel like there
were
a lot of risky behaviors going on with
teenagers dressed up in costume
yeah i think everybody's had their own i
mean actually our uh class action part
twitter i
throughout tweet a couple days ago that
was literally what's your action part
growing up
and i said i think i said like abandoned
factories and quarries are acceptable
answers uh you know so i think some
people will give us
like oh yeah this like shady water park
or this news mark then some people are
like
oh yeah that old farm we used to break
into and tip
cows and like that kind of stuff and so
i think everybody has their
their experience from that era what
about you chris
um we grown up in east texas each
county had their own state fair
and so the the fair would come into town
with the jinky rides
there was this thing called the
gravatron that sucked you into the
the walls i've done plenty of vomiting
in the gravitron actually
goes right back on you yeah and today i
don't know how that technology worked
um i think unsafely
i think it works unsafely unsafely so
and you see the town drunk that they
hired for the week
working it and that was a bit of the the
action part for us but we also
we had this pit like this sulfur pit
and um they just stopped digging sulfur
out of it
and it i think they hit something and it
turned into like a
sulfur type lake that made awesome
cliffs to jump off of
and so we would jump off of this these
cliffs
and we would reek and it would get in
your mouth and it was so bitter
we had no clue what we were jumping into
but like to this day i'm cancer free
[Laughter]
well good good good glad you didn't jump
in too far yeah
i got somebody asking about their
specific uh um
uh action park have you guys come across
something called marshall
hall in the washington dc area i grew up
in dc
and i don't know about marshall hall so
it must have been uh
very cool like a little too cool for me
maybe uh
yeah yeah all right well
uh that one's dead um
so you know this is for film
independence so we have a lot of uh
filmmakers
that are watching um and you know push
me away if this is too
personal a question but one of these uh
on here from alva
asking uh how you got funding uh as fast
as you guys did from the chronology that
you laid out it seemed like it was about
two months
yeah the answer is we didn't like um you
know
we we just started rolling cameras and
uh you know we uh we we put together a
small crew and started rolling cameras
and uh worried about that other kind of
stuff later
is really what we did and um so now like
we we didn't we just didn't and and to
piggyback on what seth
said our small crew uh you look at other
documentaries and it's like
a crew of like 50 people our core group
what
less than 10 yeah most of the people in
the credits are like you know the kind
of
people the post-production kind of like
tuning things up whatever else but
throughout most of the production
everything
it was like five people really total you
know
um is a film independent member
uh christian johnson and i believe
yeah yeah i think he might be uh um
on on this uh on this presentation
but i committed this to chris chris
lives in las vegas and chris has
this huge production van with all the
gadgets in the
the the top cameras and i just went to
chris and like hey man we have this
documentary
we think it's going to be amazing and
chris trusted
us and trusted the process and we
filmed in he drove that van from
from new jersey our whole
and our other dp rob that was it and we
drove the new jersey and we
used to check the move yeah
in a way yeah wait you guys shot all
your interviews in a week
no no no no there's caveats there we we
the the initial
stretch of them was basically a week and
a half in the tri-state area and then we
did some pickups later
and whatnot but yeah most of this movie
was shot a week and a half
wow how long did you take uh did it take
you guys to edit
the year yeah i mean it's always the
lopsided
deal how much footage
did you cut down from do you know how
much how much you compiled like with the
home videos
it was uh well the interviews themselves
were over 40 hours
yeah that's a lot yeah we had a lot a
lot and
the home movies we added a lot to a lot
uh you know it's we have a lot there's
there's a there's a b-side movie in
there somewhere you know
i'm sure yeah do you guys have any plans
did oh go ahead
when i say this like our crew i gotta
give shout out to our crew
uh chris lon our first editor in um
in shreveport louisiana who's edited a
lot of our things
i say that i'm a good filmmaker but with
chris lyon i'm an award-winning
filmmaker
he is just an incredible talent and
roxinska
our b-roll photographer he has been on
every project that i've had
the guy just has a knack and an eye
and we we did this lean we did this mean
and we we made a beautiful feature
league documentary
with a small crew and dare i say that
this is the way we move forward making
movies
uh during this pandemic and probably
afterwards
but i believe that action part beyond
its
great critic reviews is the uniqueness
of this is how we produce this how we
shot this
with a small crew and an incredibly
talented crew
what's next to the crew do you guys have
something lined up in the pipe
oh yeah there's only so much we can talk
about right now my friend
very ominous very super ominous yeah
um let's see what else we got here
well frankly i don't have any other i
don't have any other audience questions
and we got four more minutes so we can
just talk about whatever you guys want
to talk about at this point
build out something there i think the
only reason this kind of production was
possible
is because as a journalist who've been
studying this topic for a decade i came
with everything already like the sources
the archival like the everything ready
to roll
and i think what made our partnership so
interesting of like journalists and
filmmaker
together is how that makes the
production so efficient
and so when i look at like what kind of
projects i want to do and i look at one
of the big gaps that exists in the
documentary world
to me it's this chasm that exists
between journalists and between the
filmmaking world
because i think journalists are some of
the best storytellers best researchers
have these access have access often have
inroads in two worlds and they're just
sitting there
most of them laid off right now and if i
was selling a documentary filmmaker like
how do you go about
telling a good story find a journalist
find a journalist who's got
the inroads who's got the sources he's
got the archival who can like flip a
switch
and make that story happen and that's
who you work with is what i would say
and i think what made our partnership so
great is is
that journalism like bringing those two
things together
and it's something that i don't i don't
see happening much and i'm shocked i
don't see it happening much
yeah yeah the trust uh when when there
were things so like i don't
uh i always defer to
seth's journalism career and his
background i just always referred to it
uh and it it it made a great movie
um but since we have some so a few
minutes can i ask seth a question
seth what was your favorite story that
was cut
from the documentary all right so i
guess i got a lot but one of my
favorites uh
that okay so there's a there's like the
first part was cut the second part i
just learned about
so we briefly mentioned in the movie a
security guard talks about
how he had heard that the owner of the
park gene kept a machine gun in his desk
a mac 10
sub machine gun the longer story which
was cut from the film because it just
dragged on a little bit was that he had
actually broken into gene's office to
look for this machine gun with the
intention
of like shooting cans for fun like and
the idea being that if gene
uh would never report this because it
was an illegal gun in the first
place but when he bought the gene's
office the gun wasn't there
well what i only found out a couple
weeks ago speaking to another action
park employee
was why that gun wasn't there and that's
that the other action park employee who
i spoke to had the exact same idea
and a couple weeks earlier had broken
into gene's office
found the gun shot it for fun and that
in those
in that period gene had i suppose
realized that his desk drawer was not
the best place to keep a machine gun
jesus oh my god and this is a park
that's basically staffed by
teenagers and kids right who all know he
has a machine gun and are literally
breaking in to play with it
oh my god yeah i mean it sounds like
just the next ride that he would have
come up with break into my office and
shoot my machine gun
yeah well um i want to wrap it up
by uh one sharing a comment from gary
blemer
saying that he just wanted to tell you
guys as a jersey boy born and raised in
rahway
this was the truest depiction of true
jerseyites in life in the 80s i've ever
seen
nice so that's awesome that's that
we hear that and then if we had gone
wrong the whole state of new jersey
just like somebody belly flopping off
the tarzan swing would have let us know
they would have the states are high the
stakes are high
like the whole state of new jersey would
have been yeah you guys [ __ ] up but
no but uh the response from locals from
vernon knights from new jersey from
people who worked at the park
has been overwhelming and that that
you know we're gratified not because we
made a movie designed to please people
this movie clearly doesn't please some
people
but because if we had gotten it wrong
they would have let us know yeah
well it's a well-deserved praise it's an
incredible movie an insightful story
and a very interesting feeling to walk
away from
uh it's on hbo max right now class
action park
thank you so much seth and chris for
sitting down with film independent i
hope you guys uh
i hope that next ominous project is
fantastic and that you're staying safe
in these times
thank you thanks alex you guys are doing
awards work here
yeah yeah yeah sure thanks man if
anybody wants to reach out to us and say
hi just like
class action park gmail.com you know
cool
say hi say hi they're lovely people to
talk to i can testify for firsthand
experience
sure thank you guys